Emmanuel Chase parmi les premières
personnes à se féliciter de cette
avancée il y a notamment le président
Zelenski
oui tout à fait
donc le port de détail hier vous l'avez
mentionné quelques semaines près d'un
mois après que la Russie ait quitté cet
accord sur les céréales cet accord dit
de la mer Noire et surtout après 7 7
campagnes de frappe contre les peurs
contre les entrepôts de céréales
ukrainien ce sont notamment ses frappes
qui ont décidé le gouvernement
ukrainien a finalement mettre en place
ce corridor temporaire pour permettre à
certains des navires qui étaient bloqués
dans les ports depuis plus d'un an et
demi bloqué avec toute leur cargaison à
bord de continuer leur voyage le Joseph
shooter vous l'avez indiqué était
maintenant en eau romaine il transporte
à son bord 30 000 tonnes de cargaison
dont des céréales il navigue malgré les
menaces proférées par la Russie à
l'encontre de tout navire qui qui
partirait ou qui se rendrait dans un
port ukrainien puisque la Russie a
déclaré que tout que de tels navires
pouvaient être considéré comme des
cibles donc c'est un c'est un voyage
test si l'on peut dire pour ce navire de
cargaison le Joseph Schulte actuellement
en euromaine Emmanuel pendant ce temps
les combats se poursuivent évidemment
ils sont toujours très intenses sur les
différentes lignes de France
ils sont très intenses mais l'Ukraine a
déclaré hier à voir affirmé hier avoir
libéré le village Dolo China
souvenez-vous un village qui avait été
libéré par les troupes ukrainiennes dans
la région de Donia ce qu'il y a trois
semaines maintenant on avait plus
entendu d'annonces de libération dans
cette région depuis donc c'est très
symbolique pour les Ukrainiens des
images ont circulé ce matin montrant ce
village de Rosa est libéré montrant les
forces russes fuyant à l'arrivée des
soldats Ukrainiens c'est tout un symbole
c'est aussi important puisque
aujourd'hui le gouvernement russe a
proposé une nouvelle loi qui
condamnerait la diffusion d'image de
vidéos montrant montrant ces troupes en
difficulté donc on pense à tout les
blogueurs russes qui qui transmettent
des informations sur ce front qui
apparemment ne pourront plus le faire à
l'aide d'images donc on voit que cet
armée russe se sent en tout cas s'est
passé par les images qui circulent les
observateurs internationaux notent
également des avancées des forces
ukrainiennes dans la région de zapolija
dans la direction de robotisée
[Musique]